[Musique]
plastique papier carton métal ouvert
plusieurs contenants et emballages
prennent depuis près de 30 ans le chemin
des centres de tri dans cette jungle de
matières diverses
savons-nous vraiment ce qui se recycle
ou pas il ya plusieurs centres de tri
qui desservent municipalité donc selon
qu'elles sont de très bonnes aux
matières les matières acceptées sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes faits des bases
parcours est ce que c'est un combat est
ce que sur l'emballage ou à l'imprimé si
on répond non à une lourde est question
d'un grand 2 est-ce que ça va aller dans
le bac de recyclage les papier ou carton
sont les matières facilement
identifiable papier venant papier
imprimé circulaire un papier journal
pour tous ses papiers leur facilement on
met dans le bac de récupération
ensuite tous les contenants de verre
sont récupérables et des technologies
qui se développe pour recycler le verre
qu'on en refaisant les bouteilles de
verre mais en le réintégrant dando
procédé dans du béton dans faire ça dans
du pays de verre dans les meubles signés
avec d'autres matières donc on a tous
fait quand même une autre vie aux verts
qui est en train de se développer par
exemple du côté des métaux c'est simple
tout contenu se recycle les conserve les
canettes en aluminium consignés ou pas
puis les assiettes ou même le papier
d'aluminium qu'on essaie de regrouper le
plus possible du côté plastique il faut
se fier aux numéros dans le ruban de
mobius sur l'emballage de 1 à 5 et le 7
pas de problème ça se recycle ce sont
les bouteilles d'eau par exemple où les
contenants de savon à vaisselle ou à
laisser yves le plastique numéro 6
toutes les barquettes en styromousse
août ou le polystyrène ne sont pas
encore traitées à grande échelle dans
les centres de recyclage et de plusieurs
technologies et des entreprises qui
veulent aller pour reprendre la matière
et la reuss cris mais c'est long à
développer on recycle uniquement 18% du
polystyrène au québec
loin derrière l'ontario et la
colombie-britannique qui le récupère à
près de 95% et la nouvelle écosse à 100%
[Musique]
si certaines matières recyclables sont
somme toute assez évidente à reconnaître
d'autres laisse perplexe il faut que du
papier même si un petit peu de place un
bac de récupération ça ici c'est
vraiment juste deux papiers aucun
problème où on peut se poser plus de
questions c'est dans ces gens de
nouveaux emballages en place c'est clair
selon yvon potvin cyclage conclut on va
le mettre à la poubelle la même chose
pour lui qui a une portion en plastique
une portion en aluminium plusieurs
matières ensemble ils voient la peur
dans les cartons mais c'est simple les
cartons ce qu'il faut faire attention
c'est justement de boîtes de biscuits
pour retirer si jamais cela que le petit
plateau biscuits ou déployant un sac ou
six coups le retirer pour s'assurer que
le carton et restylée et s'assurer que
la barquette
alala bons numéros 6 numéros un bon mais
aussi au restylage tetra pak recyclage
tout ensemble comme ça si on au nom de
plusieurs matières oui c'est ça le
problème dans celui ci sait que
plusieurs maintien je dirai à la limite
le bouchon est recyclable parce qu'il ya
même un numéro déçu l'aluminium on
pourrait le mettre au recyclage
mais le reste de la bouteille va aller à
la poubelle
parmi les sacs de plastique on en
retrouve de toutes sortes et on se
demande souvent quoi faire avec un truc
sable si ça s'étire on recycle sinon on
gêne
malheureusement vos sacs de céréales bio
de croustilles ou de nourriture pour
animaux en plastique à la poubelle les
sacs ou pellicule qui s'étire on en fait
un sac de 5
pourquoi les sacs dans les sacs centres
de tris avait invité les chaînes les
convoyeurs si on laisse nos sacs libre
ils vont juste apprendre dans les
différents convoyeurs et ne se
retrouveront pas le secret en faisant un
sac de sac
il va vraiment suivre la chaîne il
pourrait être retiré et faire un ballot
de le rappeler que l'on peut tout mettre
mais si la collecte sélective vous
semble contraignante les résultats sont
concluants
le taux de récupération dépasse
maintenant les 60 % de matières
recyclables
[Musique]